Dark Souls 2 is in its final stages of
development with less than a month until
release I got the chance to play hours
of the full build at the Namco Bandai
office and the game isn't just good it's
incredible I know I'm biased but I know
what I want to see in a sequel and every
design decision they've made so far
impresses me on some level this is
everything I think you would like to
know let me clarify in this video I'll
be admiring the first few hours of the
gameplay design and how I felt when I
was first dropped into the world and
that's probably one of the most
important experiences to nail down in a
game since it sets the scene for
everything that's to follow so there
will be spoilers as I admire and
describe what happens but I don't want
to tell you what happens in explicit
detail so don't be too worried let's get
started
so guys remember that cursed trailer we
talked about the other week that was a
shortened version of the opening
prologue for Dark Souls 2 and you'll
remember it ends with an undead being
drawn into this swirling vortex the
narrator is an elderly woman clothed in
red who tells you that the land of
drangleic is a draw for undead because
it's a land rich with souls souls that
will help you maintain your sanity as
you fight the hollowing process of the
undead this cutscene and the gameplay to
follow really helps set the scene in
Dark Souls 2
we knew the game's story was going to be
more accessible and it immediately is
immediately you understand that the
world is overcome by an undead curse and
that the undead become more and more
Hollow until they become insane you've
been drawn into the world of drangleic
because that's a draw for people like
you and that's all you know and it sets
up your character even if you don't
indulge in the deeper story in Dark
Souls 2 at least you know this much and
at least I won't have to explain this in
every one of my law videos now anyway at
the end of the cinematic you're drawn
into the vortex and the screen fades out
to black so then we get a fade into the
gameplay and your character awakens in a
little shrine in the middle of a dark
underground forest with huge trees and
grass that comes up to your neck clothed
in rags you wake up in this huge open
area and intuitively you know the way to
go there's this blue light source
shining through a crack in the roof of
the cave in the distance and you make
your way towards it and that's another
good element of game design knowing
which way to go without a giant air
pointing you the right way this
immediately sets up that navigation
style you're used to in a Seoul series
weather design of a level inspires your
intuition and tells you which way to go
rather than some quest log or compass
you know so as you head towards this
light source you begin to walk through
this little clearing you don't have any
weapons your health bar is tiny and if
you're really paying attention it almost
feels like there's something wrong at
this point it's completely silent and in
this little clearing between the tall
grass you see small piles of human bones
picked clean you're really really aware
of your vulnerability right now and the
first time I came through here I was
apprehensive and then a pile of bones
was disrupted and broke apart as a small
black dog dashed through the grass and
passed my character you instantly feel
like you're in trouble and without any
weapons and a tiny amount of health you
feel like you need to move another dog
dashes past you and you realize there
are a bunch of them in this small grass
sort of just testing you and nipping at
your heels to see how you respond wait
here too long and you become another
pile of bones but if you respond the way
the devs want you to you'll feel a bit
vulnerable and you'll try to escape in
the logical direction forward because in
the distance you see this warm sort of
man-made light illuminating a tree it
looks like a safe haven and it is you
cross a small wooden bridge past this
waterfall you see this farm at the front
of the tree and you realize there's this
door carved into the wood you open it
and a short cutscene begins to play now
sorry guys I'm not gonna spoil the
dialogue for you but there's this group
of old women inside the hut who mock you
just like they mock all the visitors who
come through here and the character
creation screen is triggered here and
it's triggered in a really clever way
the old women ask you whether you
remember your own name and then you
enter your own name and then they give
you a human effigy as a reward for
sharing they then ask you whether you
see yourself within this human effigy
and then you create your own character
so character creation itself hasn't
changed drastically although the layout
is nicer classes to choose from were
warrior Knight swordsmen bandits
sorcerer cleric and deprived the gifts
were really interesting though so let's
talk about it there were more balanced
this time around with no clear standouts
like the master key there was a good
selection of consumable items like
effigy
healing items homeward bones and there
was also a ring that increased your
maximum HP by a little but the three
most interesting by far were at the
bottom of the list one was a seed of a
tree of giants which had the most
confusing description that gave no clues
about what to use it for all that said
was that it was inedible
the second was and I quote petrified
something the description implies that
you'll be able to unpatrolled and if I
was going to choose something on my
first playthrough I think I'd choose
this or the seed I just mentioned since
you don't know what to use them for at
the start of the game but I assume
you'll be able to use them later on and
the most interesting to me was the last
item bonfire ascetic an item you can
burn into a bonfire to increase the
difficulty of enemies who spawn near
that bonfire and you guys are gonna love
this concept not just this item but the
general trend eyesore in Dark Souls 2
even from my short playthrough was that
there was this focus on longevity the
game is being designed to be played over
and over again in different ways every
time and there's a few things I've seen
so far that increased the difficulty or
change the playthrough somehow and I've
heard rumors about new game+ featuring
different enemy placements and all of
this is just this amazing way to
increase difficulty why have different
difficulty modes in a game like hard
mode or easy mode when you can put in
these optional ways to increase
difficulty or change difficulty within
the actual game design ways that don't
just increase the damage enemies do they
change behavior and level design instead
and this makes me so happy because from
what I've seen we're going to be playing
this game for years without getting
bored and if we can play Dark Souls for
two years without getting bored I think
we'll be able to make do with this game
anyway you finish your character
creation and you're dismissed by the old
women they basically tell you that your
journey is destined to fail and that
you'll lose your souls all of them over
and over again so you emerge from the
hut feeling pretty [ __ ] about yourself
and now it's time to get control over
the game mechanics you go over this thin
strip of land between these huge tree
trunks this strip leads straight into
the distance and you can see an exit far
ahead
however on your left and right are four
gates leading into the trees
and this this is your optional tutorial
level within the hollow trees our
gravestones that have the controls and
mechanics written on them and there are
enemies conveniently placed to
demonstrate these mechanics in use
you'll meet a familiar friend in this
tutorial so I recommend you go through
it just to hear her shrill voice you
approach the end of the tutorial and
approach the crack that climbs up
towards the ceiling bringing this dim
light to the entire area you just made
your way through and looking back
there's a ton of hidden loot in this
zone as well as some really mysterious
areas so when you find yourself here on
March 11th or March 14th take a look at
every little nook leave no stone
unturned this is the tutorial and
introductory area of Dark Souls 2 and I
really like it while it's a bit of a
departure from previous games that
featured a huge boss at the end it
really sets the tone of this series
introducing new players to their role as
a cursed undead and and giving you this
initiation experience where you start
off with nothing but you end up as a
warrior of your choosing
armed with the mechanics of the game and
ready to venture outside this closed off
zone which can be speedrun in less than
two minutes you venture through this
crevasse and for a while it's nothing
but darkness and not being able to see
where you're going but eventually you
see this light spilling in from outside
you run for this light because you've
been drawn towards it the entire
tutorial and you're initially blinded by
this light as you exit the cavern your
eyes are just to look over the ocean and
you see this strip of land that you'll
be venturing back to over and over again
this is medulla and it represents what
filing shrine does in Dark Souls or what
the Nexus does in Demon Souls this is
your new place of rest when nothing is
trying to kill you and trust me when I
say this when you first come to medulla
you're going to want to explore just
like in the tutorial there are a ton of
hidden items and some really important
NPCs to introduce herself to and I mean
really important the first time I played
this game I didn't talk to the woman by
the bonfire and as a result I didn't get
the most important item in the game so
who is this woman
she's the Emerald Herald are you the
next monarch or merely a pawn of fate
bearer of the curse I will remain by
your side till this frail hope shatters
take this with you so it may ease your
burden reminiscent of the maiden in
black from demon souls this woman is
going to be a central part of your
playthrough it takes you a long time to
exhaust her dialogue as she tells you
stories about the world about the
surrounding areas and the humans and
creatures that have come to inhabit it
and then she gives you a Nestor's flask
notice how I said
Estus flask singular one Estus flask one
charge of this Estus flask is all you'll
get healing in Dark Souls 2 has changed
more than we expected you start the game
with one charge of Estes so you can only
take one sip before it's depleted as you
make your way through the world you'll
find Estes shards emerald shards that
you can give to the emerald maiden who
will fuse them into your flask so you
can carry more estes with you and
kindling has changed too I believe you
can burn a human effigy at the bonfire
to essentially Kindle that bonfire but
instead of this giving you more charges
it makes Estes heal you more in earlier
videos I talked about life gems which
are consumable healing items that can be
bought or found in the world and they're
excellent and mainly intended for use
between battles when you have time to
consume them Estes is more of an in
combat item now I think and and it's
sort of for when your character is in a
pinch and needs to heal fast healing
seems to be much more balanced and much
more logical in Dark Souls 2 and it's
very very limited at the start of the
game so this really teaches new players
the value of health but giving you more
Estus flasks isn't all the maiden does
for you she'll now be the one who levels
up your character like you used to be
able to do at the bonfire this means
you'll be able to walk back to majula
often just like you should return to the
Nexus and Demon Souls this is an
interesting design choice and I guess
it's sort of the developers saying
medulla is important we want you to come
back here to rest often to think about
how to spend your souls and to encourage
you to explore this area and see how it
changes it makes you talk to the NPC's
and really cements majula as a place of
rest somewhere you can come to
contemplate what you've achieved before
heading back out into the
world I've played the first area you
meant to go to which is called the
forest of the Giants it's similar to the
undead burg from Dark Souls in terms of
enemies and that's what you're seeing
playing through on the screen here as
we've come to expect from a Souls game
the gameplay is well designed enemy
placement is brilliant this time around
and every encounter feels special
there's this one gameplay example I can
show footage of it's this grassy area
where you're fighting these hollow
soldiers that are waking up at a steady
rate as well as dealing with one Archer
shooting crossbow bolts from above
there are ambushes there are multiple
ways to approach situations and there
are ways to deal with irritating enemies
before they become an annoyance it's
just a Souls game in its pure form and
every little gameplay experience is well
thought out and executed honestly guys I
could spoil so much more for you but I
just wanted to give you a taste
something that leaves your imagination
wanting more so this is where we'll
leave it for now in terms of progression
but there are so many different items
and gameplay changes I want to talk to
you about and I'll cover them so much
more in depth in my next video which
will be a video answering all the best
questions you left me a couple of weeks
ago there are so many new features to
talk about voice chat the fact that you
have four ring slots now all the
information regarding PvP it's all great
make sure you watch that video in terms
of the game design similar to what I've
talked about in this video there's a lot
more I want to spoil but I believe in
only making a video if I can make it
well and I just don't have the right
game footage to convey this design to
you right now considering I'm using
screenshots for this video I feel like
this video is long enough there's
something else I want to talk to you
about though the reason I explicitly
didn't talk about story or gameplay is
because I actually feel like saying
these things would ruin the experience
for you I don't want to be responsible
for that and I recommend you tune out
all story spoilers until March 11th
because this is the point where some
people are playing the actual game we're
no longer speculating we're actually
telling you what's taking place and I
think talking about the gameplay
mechanics is fine but in my opinion we
should talk about story and discuss most
gameplay experiences on launch when
everyone gets to experience it not now
obviously other uploaders are going to
draw that line at different points so
you can't blame people for telling you
about
but for me you're gonna get so much
content out of me when dark souls2 airs
that I might as well be the only one on
your subscription feed so if you haven't
already subscribed in that hope and if
you're looking to hear more detailed
Dark Souls 2 first impressions click the
links in the description my next video
will be my Q&A answers video and they'll
give you so many more amazing answers
with everything I learned from playing
there are a lot of new features to talk
to you about anyway let me know what you
thought in the comments below I do try
to read them all and I'll be down there
chatting with you guys I'll see you guys
next time